hi today i'd uh like to talk about
fear and um
and expanding in where that will go
i still personally find that if i'm
going to take a seminar after all these
years i still
have times when i get up and i think i'm
about to go off to
go on a journey perhaps a flight
and you all of a sudden get this
horrible feeling of
inadequacy it's perhaps not the thing
that many people want to talk about you
know
the big scentsy is coming to enlighten
everybody
but the fear of will i be good enough to
teach them what
i want them to to hear what i want them
to see
i don't know i'm sure a lot of people
get it i i know that they say
that people in
in the art world feared it
but you know are we inadequate
now this is one of the biggest we'll say
fears that we could have
and it and depending on what you're like
when you're standing with somebody in
front of a ken
or joe and you're about to do partner
practice
you might be what i call the twitching
mind
even even though if you know that it's
your turn to go first
make the first movement you might still
be apprehensive about
am i ready to make the first move
will i mess it up will i get it right
you know all these stupid things going
through our mind
but these are the things that no
teachers talk about
they stand in front of you year in year
out on seminars showing you the
techniques that they
want you to perform you know
we're all the other side of the the
teacher
hoping that we're going to be
enlightened today's the day we're going
to get the technique
we're going to feel great or there's
those that just go there
you know you're buzzing with energy you
want to get on with the seminar
excuse me
we we get the the buzz
so the the the joy overrides
the problems of fear fear may be a
strong word to use
inadequacy is also a word that we might
not want to face
but i'm sure the teachers as well as the
students face it because
as teachers we are students
those who who don't have this problem
you may suffer from the word arrogance
if you're an arrogant person you will
think that whatever you do is correct
the years i've looked at people who i
admire because
they seem to not do anything wrong
they step on the mat they have the right
postures
they have really good aikido
but are they when they go into their own
little
dark corners of their mind do they feel
inadequate
do they really struggle to to
perfect the art do they struggle
to keep this plateau that they have been
put on
by their self and others
can they stay up there is this a fear
that they worry that they may lose
so it's just being a human being isn't
it
i haven't found anybody who isn't
stubborn
now you could say to the point of being
obnoxious
some are very positive about what they
want to say
their opinions very opinionated
to the point where perhaps if you're a
calm or quiet
person or wiser person
you think to yourself oh okay i don't
think i will bring that subject up or
i think i should stop now not push this
subject
because whatever i say that person is
not going to listen
there's also the person who is very
placid really nice people
but are they nice inside are they
are they fearing
if they said anything out of turn would
it hurt them
in a physical internal way because they
don't want to
upset anyone but they will still be
stubborn
um i was offering somebody wanted it
had a headache they didn't have uh
any pills on them
and on the box it says take two
paracetamol
for an adult over 12.
oh i've got some power sleeping when i
said
i'll get you two out oh no i only need
one
but it says on the box and i don't have
a twelve two no
i know myself i only need one
so i have to then decide am i now being
awkward because i'm trying to
run to the letter of what the pharmacy
box is saying and yet they're telling me
they only need one so perhaps they're
right along being now stubborn
but a short while later well it's a
short while
hour so later they were saying it's
starting to
clear but it still won't go and i
and i had to have the winning say by
where you should have had taken two and
by now it would have gone
so we we are
naturally born i think to either argue
or have these points of stubbornness
and yet within ourself we can fear
this takes me on to teaching
the teachers that i've noticed
if a japanese teacher is coming to
hold a seminar people will flock from
all styles they'll go there because the
name of the teacher
is renowned and also they're japanese
and because aikido is japanese we think
that they're going to
automatically enlighten us
if you're from a different style you may
fear that yours will not fit in
you might think your style is better
than theirs
stronger than theirs but you still want
to fit in don't you
we want to be like one of the sheep in
the pack we don't want to
upset anyone or be outside
you may worry that your aikido is not
strong enough to compete with the
particular style that this teacher
is renowned for doing
what i have come to learn is and i don't
mean this
in any derogative way against any
particular japanese teacher
but what i have noticed over the many
years
is they don't teach any better
if the younger ones are more dynamic yes
they might be a lot sterner than a
westerner
but they've got to go through the
translation barrier
they're there just to show aikido
we don't we don't perhaps know their own
personalities
now the great advantage of being a
western teacher
of highway is you may not get the draw
that the japanese teachers do
those of you who have been on the last
seminars will know what i'm talking
about
but what the western teacher tries to do
is to show more compassion i think
they want to go into more detail they
actually want to help the
other person on the other side
the westerner i wonder what it would be
like a westerner teaching the japanese
aikido
i know that in japan a lot of the
westerners
that go there to fund their stay they
teach
english doesn't matter what country
you're from
doesn't have to be from england but they
teach english to get money
and the students really like that
because somebody with an english spoken
accent
is teaching the japanese english
but a westerner teaching their japanese
aikido
i don't know how they would respond to
all this fine detail that the westerner
gives
recently i was listening to an interview
by a top karate sensei
he i think he's done other martial arts
as well
but he made so much sense to me
and i thought now if only
we could have that explained
by a japanese master
the art would go a lot further
the one thing that struck me was i'm
always complaining in my
mind and when when i look at ikea on
youtube i'm always complaining about
how weak their people's aikido is and
how terribly
incorrect it is the precision
is far from good
and he was talking about in karate they
have carter's
well we have a joe carter yes we have
some
in the roux school
but he was saying that
if you have to perform carter's with the
body you have to be precise and you have
to do the carters
correct now in aikido there's some every
style is different depending on the
human being
i don't know if this is a good thing or
bad
but when people are using the joe
and i'm watching them on youtube they
don't cover their head
they hold it in a straight line
and the joe is very thin
and you can see both sides of my head
it's supposed to protect the head like
this it's supposed to be a diagonal
cover to cover the whole of the head and
shoulders
so if we were to learn body carters in
aikido
we would have to be precise or i
actually wouldn't get your next rank
so that's something i think that
teachers should worth
considering looking at more preciseness
it's okay being compassionate and
wanting to
talk about things
but detail so this so i see it as
technic aikido's technical and
spiritual now the spiritual to me is
you as a person trying to better
yourself and to face
yourself so going back right back to the
beginning
fear
fearing when i get it right fearing
feeling
fearing did i move too quick
if it's partner against partner with the
weapons
and you're waiting for them to move are
you
settled in yourself okay
so this is my take
for today on uh
where we should look at ourselves more
now if you would wish it's a free choice
you can join it you can cancel you don't
have to be a member for life
and it's a small plug for my patreon
page
but in my patreon site i am giving away
fine detail through every stage of the
body arts the weapons and i'm going to
try to
give those students the secrets
that i hold the secrets that teacher
perhaps
won't dare say about and the things i've
talked about
today here so you don't
have to but
become a contributor but
you also can just take this film and
think about what i'm saying
face yourself overcome the fear
or the inadequacy and
polish it make it smoother make it so
it's not going to bother you so much
and when it does bother you face it head
on
and work out why you're fearing it and
what you can do about
it because always saying i don't know
why
i feel it i don't know what to do about
it
won't make this any more complete in
your aikido
or you as a human being than you are
sitting here listening to this
standing whatever you're doing thank you
for your time
and please subscribe to my youtube
channel because that month's free
if you wish thank you goodbye